[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we have therefore to see how pure
insight and intention behaves in its
negative attitude to that other which it
finds confronting it pure insight and
intention which takes up a negative
attitude can only be since its notion is
all essentiality and there's nothing
outside of it the negative of itself as
insight therefore it becomes the
negative of pure insight becomes untruth
and unreasoned and as intention it
becomes the negative of pure intention
becomes a lie and insincerity of purpose
paragraph 547 is rather short and it's a
transitional paragraph because in the
paragraphs before where he talked about
pure insight through the Enlightenment
diffusing itself not only into the
culture in general but also into faith
he ended up saying in the previous
paragraph right before that that it no
longer had any antithesis now that's not
gonna last forever everything winds up
sooner or later finding a new antithesis
or attaining some complete
reconciliation and and winding up in a
new stage of consciousness a new a new
shape a new Gestalt right that's not
happening here we're actually at the
beginning of that development and what
we see here is the old Hegelian thing of
the self same repelling itself from
itself and being attracted to its other
or to its negation in this case we have
actually both of those things going on
so he says we have to see how pure
insight and intention behaves in its
negative attitude towards that that
other that it fry it finds confronting
it so what is that other we're gonna get
to that in just a moment so a little bit
before we go on we've been using these
terms insight and intention throughout
this this section and I do want to just
signal that both of these are very close
lexically in in German right we have
Isaac literally sort of like seeing into
the critical aspect and then on Zeke to
the intention you know the the seeing
towards you might say or seeing about
and/or seeing - there's actually a nice
way you know I'm going to see to this be
I intend to do that so when these
constitute and other in relation to
themselves that they can negate is that
other really going to be faith as we've
had so far or is it going to be
something different and the answer of
course is yes
both of them at the same time but this
is very important because what this
means is that for self consciousness or
for spirit at this point in time you
know as it's developing itself in terms
of this historical movement of the
Enlightenment basing itself on pure
insight it's gonna find out that when
push comes to shove it's not everything
that it portrays itself as being so he
says pure insight and intention which
takes up a negative attitude can only be
the negative of itself so the other is
indeed pure insight and intention but
being understood in a different way why
is this he says because it's notion is
all essentiality and there is nothing
outside of it the very fact that it's
one in the way that it has means that in
a certain sense it's now ripe for losing
so what is that going to look like
well Hegel tells us right pure insight
becomes it's negative the negative pure
inside becomes untruth becomes is a very
interesting idea unreason so untruth
both in the sense of having lost you
know the little hold upon truth that it
had where you know as usual it had lost
certainty but a gain truth in the
process now it's finding it's actually
lost that and it's also unreasoned now
that's a big problem because reason is
going to be the hallmark of the
Enlightenment so how can reason which is
being opposed to faith become unreason
how can it become irrationally
rationalistic you might say that that is
something that we have to look at pure
intention on the other hand he says
becomes the negative of pure intention
it becomes a lie and in sincerity of
purpose or in sincerity of end of vak
so notice what he's saying here here in
insight pure intention as they're
opposing themselves find themselves now
he doesn't use the word at that point as
pure insider pure intention he says that
intention and incite themselves find
themselves opposed to pure insight to
pure intention and so you might say that
what we have here is a movement of the
self from this side over here to this
side where we have intention and we have
insight and they are in their own turn
saying against pure intention that it is
untruth and unreason that pure pure pure
insight and pure intention is a lie and
in sincerity of purpose so there's
something about the purity here that
actually winds up being you might say
counterproductive now this is a
dialectic of course so this is going to
be productive in one sense but not not
in the scope of this paragraph now we
have to look at the much longer
paragraphs to come
it entangles itself in this
contradiction through engaging in
dispute and imagines that what it is
attacking is something other than itself
it only imagines this for its essence as
absolute negativity implies that it
contains that other nacelle f--
the absolute notion is the category in
that notion knowing and the object known
are the same consequently what pure
insight produces to be its other what it
asserts to be an error or a lie can be
nothing else but its own self it can
condemn only what it is itself what is
not rational has no truth or what is not
grasps conceptually is not when
therefore reason speaks of something
other than itself it speaks in fact only
of itself so doing it does not go
outside of itself the struggle with its
antithesis therefore also has the
significance of being the actualization
of insight for this consists precisely
in the process of developing the moments
and taking them back into itself when
part of this process is the
differentiation in which intellectual
insight confronts its own self is object
so long as it persists in this
relationship
it is alienated from itself as pure
insight it is devoid of all content the
process of its realization consists in
its making itself its content for
nothing else can become its content
because it is the self-consciousness of
the category but since in confronting
the content pure insight at first knows
it only as a content and not yet as its
own self it does not recognize itself in
it complete insight is therefore
attained when the content which to begin
with was objective 2 it is recognized as
its own its result however will thus be
neither the reestablishment of the
errors it struggles against nor merely
its original notion bought an insight
which recognizes the absolute negation
of itself to be its own actual existence
to be its own self or an insight whose
notion recognizes its own self this
nature of the struggle of the
Enlightenment with errors that of
fighting itself in them and of
condemning in them what it self asserts
is explicit for us or what enlightenment
and its straw
is in itself it is the first aspect of
this struggle however the defilement of
enlightenment through the adoption by
its self identical purity of a negative
attitude that is an object for faith
which therefore comes to know it as
falsehood unreason and as
ill-intentioned just as enlightenment
regards faith as error and prejudice as
regards its content it is in the first
instance an empty insight whose content
appears to it to be something other than
itself consequently it finds it given in
the shape of a content which is not yet
its own as something that exists quite
independently of it finds it given in
faith
now in paragraph 548 Hegel is going to
continue this examination of what we
could call the negativity and the
self-deception inherent in the
Enlightenment which is relying upon pure
insight or here he's going to talk about
reason or rationality as its its primary
not what not just mode or tool but
really it's its essence and it's an
essence that is trying to discover what
its essence is so it's you know if you
think about what it is that insight or
reason is supposed to be doing on the
one hand it's there as a sort of
positivity as here's what you know
reason consists in but reason is an
unfinished project and that's something
that he's not talking about this here
but that's something that we can say
about enlightenment in in general so he
talks about it entangling itself in this
contradiction and you know contradiction
there is is a strong term that that's
important there there really is a
fundamental contradiction not just an
antithesis here that that's being
developed and it's one that you know the
subject is going to have to work its way
through so how does it wind up in this
contradiction this is where it gets
really curious the way that Hegel has it
phrased it entangles itself in this
contradiction through engaging in
dispute now what let's pause on that for
a moment you would say well the
contradiction generally occurs when the
dispute occurs or we dispute because
there's already a contradiction there
Hegel is saying no the very act of
engaging in dispute is actually
deepening the contradiction it's making
it more contradictory it's making the
the subject the the person of pure
insight get entangled within it so that
the person of enlightenment has never
really able to fulfill the enlightenment
that they're representing or seeking so
he says what's going on it imagines that
what it is attacking is something other
than itself and we just saw that what is
being portrayed as other is really the
self of pure insight or of reason the
self of the subject the south of the
person who is you know portraying
themselves as being part of the
Enlightenment they are you might say
casting their demons outside of
themselves so that in that externalized
form they can be criticized forgetting
that they came from within themselves
yeah this is a very interesting point
you know when people are talking about
oh you know we have to go back to to the
Enlightenment and don't go in to
postmodernity because you know that's a
critique of reason and says that reason
isn't fully rational you know well
that's there in Hegel and Hegel sees
that as part of the Enlightenment itself
that critique of the Enlightenment
happens by what is happening through the
Enlightenment it is not something that
we can push aside if we do we risk not
seeing how these things develop and and
any possible reconciliation so he says
it imagines what it's attacking is
something other than itself and he says
it only imagines this though and then
imagine is important right imagination
is the realm of picture thinking of
force telling it is not the realm of
conceptual thinking and the big riff the
concept the notion and what we have here
is a notion that that is operative that
is developing itself but it doesn't
fully recognize what it is so he goes on
he says it's essences absolute
negativity implies it contains that
other nacelle fit should be recuperating
that other nasai dove itself and taking
a look it says it should say oh crap
that's in me that is me but it's not
doing that so Hegel says the absolute
notion is the category in
notion knowing and the object known are
the same that is that is what is you
might say analogical or metaphysical
basis going on but the the person of
pure insight is not recognizing this
this is why there is a dialectical
process going on here because of this
misrecognition
so he says what pure insight pronounces
to be its other what it asserts to be an
error or a lie can be nothing else but
its own self that's important
it can condemn only what it is itself so
when it appears to be condemning the
culture when it appears to be condemning
faith it's actually condemning itself by
taking the sort of privileged position
that would allow it to survey everything
and to say I am the reasonable I am the
rational everybody else is error and
lies it's really talking about itself
without realizing it this is a
fundamental insight I think that Hegel
has here so he goes on and he says what
is not rational
what what is being criticized over here
notice there's three things that he says
about this and we want to attend to each
of these what is not rational has no
truth or what does not grasp
conceptually is not so we have three
distinctions here and we actually have
four what is not being grasped
conceptually what is only being imagined
what is only being reasoned about but in
an irrational way Hegel talks about
philosophies of the understanding you
know Locke is a prime example of this
for Hegel as opposed to philosophies of
reason and philosophies in that of the
understanding are primarily using force
telling or a representation picture
thinking in order to to do their work
and they're not grasping things
conceptually by not grasping things
conceptually this other is thereby
portrayed as not being rational okay so
it's not rational then what is it does
that mean that its very nature is
resisting the right the
reason that is at least in principle
supposed to be able to understand
everything or is it simply not rational
in that it's perverse it does understand
reason but it's not using it well he
googles a little further it has no truth
here he doesn't say that it's not
truthful he says it has no truth does
that mean that it's entirely a lie does
that mean that it's beyond truth and
lying does it mean that it has no
significance
well that which is not being grasped
conceptually has no being that is an
extraordinarily strong statement to make
and of course Hegel is not saying that
oh well if we're not actually at the end
of the Hegelian dialectic nothing
actually has any any being or existence
but he is saying something important
here about how things are being
portrayed how this is being understood
by pure insight this over here is
becoming a nonentity you could say so he
goes on and he says reason speaks of
something other than itself but reason
in fact speaks only of itself in doing
so it does not go outside of itself that
means that reason in some sense well
there's two things to say that means
that reason in some sense doesn't
understand what the hell it's doing
which is a problem if it's supposed to
be reason right that also means that
reason is what is over here
reason is what lacks truth reason is
what lacks being in so far as it
encompasses this insofar as it extensive
this that means that reason in order to
grasp the totality of being or at least
just the social sphere in which it's
operating in this case has to be more
than reason and in a certain sense less
than reason to do so it has to encompass
its other it does so through crit
system or through negation we can say so
he calls this the struggle with its
antithesis and now notice what he says
he says it also has the significance of
being the actualization of insight the
being made real the being made effective
the we might even say individual
individual a ssin or being made concrete
of insight because you know insight by
itself is great
but it has to have subjects for for whom
and through whom that insight takes
place so he says this consists this
actualization in the process of
developing the moments taking them back
into itself so there's this back and
forth back and forth going on now he
says one part of this process is this
differentiation in which intellectual
insight confronts its own self as object
the other is being treated as object
here he says so long as it persists in
this relationship
it's alienated from itself it's not
actually recognizing itself it may even
feel its loss it may feel the negation
involved in the antithesis or in the
contradiction that's that's going on
here so it is not yet what it ought to
be now he goes on and he says as pure
insight it is devoid of all content that
was remember back that was one of the
characteristics of pure insight as
opposed to faith pure insight did not
have a content it it was in a certain
sense parasitical it needed to get its
content from something else now when
pure insight is being applied to itself
not recognizing this as its other or
recognizing that its other and not
recognize it gets other is itself it's
applying itself to something that is a
emptiness it becomes a you might say
pure activity right
so he says the process of its
realization consists in making itself
into its content so this is a different
sort of being made real you know if you
if you think about concepts right let's
say we're sort of you know old-school
metaphysicians and we're like well we
have the concept of a cow now let's go
get ourselves an individual cow and you
know maybe we walk out to a field and we
find an individual instance of a cow and
we say ah ha now we have some content
this is Bessie she's carrying a bell
that's this size she's brown and white
you know she gives this much milk or
something like that or you know maybe
we're scientists we make a cow in the
lab or something like that who knows you
know but the point is you have sort of a
concept and that's formal and then you
have you know the actual content and
that's an individual or perhaps a group
of individuals of some sort but that's
something real you can grasp your hands
around it what's the content with this
it's a activity it's it's looking into
its own activities and not finding
anything there unless it find some
content to stick into the mill this very
is as they say these days very meta
right so he goes on and says nothing
else can become its content why because
it's the self-consciousness of this
category but since and confronting the
content pure insight at first knows that
only as a content as this other and not
as its own self it does not recognize
itself in it that's a fundamental
problem at this point so he says its
result is not going to be the
reestablishment of errors that it
struggles against nor merely its
original notion but an insight a further
insight which recognizes he says the
absolute negation of itself to be its
own actual essence insight comes now you
might say to be insight squared its
insight about insight grasping that
itself is negative and that whatever
contents it finds that it's going to
negate or work upon or criticize it can
actually do that to itself and call
itself into question now that gets kind
of dangerous doesn't it so he goes on
and he says it could be an insight whose
notion recognizes its own self the
nature of the struggle of the
Enlightenment with error that of
fighting itself in them and condemning
in them what itself asserts is explicit
for us the phenomenologist looking on or
what enlightenment and its struggle is
in itself we grasp that people in the
Enlightenment don't they think that by
attacking faith and its many errors or
tyranny or whatever that they're
attacking something fundamentally
different from itself but let the
Enlightenment to actually get power and
we find out or actualization that it's
not quite so different it's not quite so
pure as it seems
again Hegel here is saying things about
not not just you know endorsing these
because he's not actually endorsing it
he is saying this is something that
comes out of enlightenment itself and
you don't have to wait a hundred and
fifty years for you know French
post-structuralist to come along and
tell you these sort of things this is
part of the Enlightenment itself this is
the lessons being learned in the
Enlightenment this is very important so
he goes on and he says this nature of
the struggle right we get it it's the
first aspect of the struggle he says the
defilement of the Enlightenment by its
adoption of a self identical purity of a
negative attitude that becomes an object
for faith so now faith which appeared to
be completely passive faith was on the
ropes faith was getting its butt kicked
by insight by enlightenment it didn't
have any agency of its own faith is
still in the background and faith looks
on and says oh wait a second
Enlightenment insight
you guys who are so critical of me for
believing in stuff and and being stuck
in error and you know being unreasonable
you've got that inside of yourself and
you just admitted it so why exactly are
you better more truthful the way to go
instead of what I have to offer
faith is able to come back on the scene
and at least you know get back in the
ring you could say so he says faith
comes to know it as falsehood unreason
and is ill-intentioned just the same way
that enlightenment regards faith is
Error and prejudice Hagel closes by
saying as regards its content it's in
the first instance an empty insight
whose content appears to it to be
something other than itself so
consequently it finds itself he says
given in the shape of a content which is
not yet its own as something that exists
quite independently of it finds it given
in faith so this paragraph closes with
reasserting a connection between insight
and faith now we have to see how that
that actually plays itself out what is
this connection between insight and
faith is it just you know this fraternal
struggle between the two now both of
them accusing each other is essentially
the same thing or is there something
more going on here
you